les réunions chez sipri alors j'ai bossé
sur un énorme projet pour la chaîne
youtube c'est très très novateur c'est
vrai que je sors de ma zone de confort
je prends un peu de risques là la
réunion 3 mai réunion iii c'est parti
chez neiman non je devais pas au psg
voilà qu'est ce que je leur dis mais tu
leur donnes un chiffre exorbitant un
truc qui peuvent pas s'offrir voilà
genre 250 millions au qatar c'est
d'accord oui belle affaire chez disney
j'ai pensé pour le prochain star wars
c'est l'histoire de la princesse leia
qui la princesse leia on peut pas à
l'acte et c'est moche mais c'est pas
grave ça on l'a fait en 3d
ah bon bah oui enfin un hologramme assez
possible bien sûr que c'est possible
regarde moi je regrette depuis le début
mais non non je déconne voici chinois
guangpu débuts en fait nous chez
desigual alors notre nouveau modèle bon
appétit et 80 au niveau des couturiers
traverser un diplomate basilic et pour
écoute pourquoi par là les fonctions je
suis prêt pour ce t-shirt vous donnez
combien j'aime à 5 euros mais pas plus
et là chez desigual mort mais pas trop
car c'est au csc chaînette que c'est
vrai qu'on a des mots français
chez facebook les mecs mettre le paquet
sur la vidéo partagée mais à quoi ça
sert exactement chez netflix ya que des
séries de super seront quoi on des gens
ils vont se lasser et c'est ce qu'il
faut faire il faut parler au patron
c'est ça dès qu'il arrive on lui dit
c'est fini c'est terminé
j'ai plein de mini c'est l'idée du
siècle c'est la méga tournée non plus
mais non on s'en fout on est déjà super
riches
j instagram compressé un petit peu comme
sur ce match ça c'est à dire des photos
et des vidéos
uniquement disponible 24 heures et c'est
super on fait comme ça au chat oui mais
par contre pour les futurs on s'était
dit qu'on pourrait changer la donne on
april est grave et tout comme sa vente
est elle le nom parce que stories c'est
vraiment la même salle des fêtes tout
comme 6-9 donne alors petite nouveauté
chez snapshot aulas le filtre
directement sur le génial je sais pas
j'ai pas pensé ça s'est passé
eh ben on a bien bossé à la prochaine
bonne foi ok il nous faut une clé bien
trop attaché le coche et plus riches
alors c'est comment on pour sa part oui
c'est génial vraiment mais je parle
d'humanité vendredi venaient me regarder
c'est juste ici qu'est-ce qui se
passerait ses congés la cadence un
attaché-case et après on était presque
archers pokémon ou non j'ai le plaisir
de vous annoncer le premier jeu pokémon
sont mobiles pokémon gauche
yakuza journal kotch pokémon chez
starbucks attendez-vous savait pas
écrire le prénom etienne on est désolé
j'y arrive pas bienvenue chez starbucks
comment décrivez gerard j parfait chez
pokémon dont une fois mise à jour vous
avez compris mieux que toi toi
j'suis instagram
il ya une énorme star qui viennent
rendre visite aujourd'hui chez instagram
mais non merci
salut je suis justin bieber le célèbre
chanteur de musique populaire j'organise
un concours qui ont des plus grands fans
vous voulez gagner des iphone il suffit
d'appeler ce numéro est de donner 12
code il n'ya pas dernier je suis justin
bieber chez pizza une taupe de chez
snapshot chez nous en tout cas c'est pas
moi c'est pas moi non plus ils sont
sélectionnés à leur bon j'avoue moi je
suis milieu ruber et moi je suis
toujours chez moi chez eux l'eau g mais
non bon j'avoue mais aussi chez les mecs
qui font les dom alors
mais du coup il est cassé là et les
clients il s'en achète un deuxième à la
halle aux chaussures est on pourrait
vendre des chaussettes
les internautes déjà à la halle aux
chaussures ils vendent aussi des
chaussettes des impôts le prix de
l'iphone dit oui j'en ai trop dit sa
ferme aux 150 ans et plus et moins 1000
euros c'est plus c'est plus que notre
série c'est plus au qatar 1329 euros 1
mais sans dec
c'est beaucoup trop cher on n'est pas
des pigeons les gens sont fous à la
maison au delà du voile autre chinois il
va chinois et les coréens ils nous
menacent
au caire ils ont fait exploser pyongyang
bancaire lui envoie sans messi n'aura
gueule 4,5 de 2,3 à la maison chrestia
je suis président je fais ce que je vous
dit rien on envoie de trois messieurs
sur les télés sur les hits annoncé trop
loin les etats unis ont en général c'est
au japon ouais ok on envoie nos trois
mais si tu en voilà c'est parti on sait
si la maison blanche et nous envoyer en
mission
oui mais c'est tombé dans l'eau oui je
ne visais pas c'était le japon pour
l'album est quand même là je pouvais la
gueule l'inversé des filets avec les
lumières
je fais le tweak est bien joué bien joué
et nettoie pas la lumière en partant sa
console c'est en poule 1
il n'oublie pas à bonn toi juste ici
pour découvrir les scènes coupées et le
bêtisier que tu vas voir c'est très
drôle
il était réservé quelques surprises